سؤالي الأول حول
الإطار الزمني الذي يستغرقه تطوير
الاستجابة المناعية المرغوبة ، كل
التعليقات
حتى الآن تدور حول تسلسل
الحصول على اللقاح
وعدد الجرعات المطلوبة التي لم يشاركها
أحد المصنّعين
مع الجمهور كم من الوقت
بعد ذلك.  التطعيم هل
يطور الجسم الاستجابة المناعية المرغوبة
مع معظم اللقاحات ، يستغرق الأمر
ما يقرب من
أسبوعين ، والسؤال الثاني هو خلال التجارب
هل ظهرت أعراض الفيروس على أي شخص
بين الجرعتين الأولى والثانية بينما
كان جهاز المناعة يكثف
بالإضافة إلى ذلك هل ظهرت أعراض على أي شخص
خلال فترة الأسبوعين
التالية للجرعة الأخيرة ، تعد هذه المعلومات مهمة
ويجب توعية الجمهور بأن
الاستجابة المناعية ليست فورية
، يجب أن يُطلب من جميع الأفراد الذين يديرون اللقاح
تمرير هذه
المعلومات إلى كل شخص يتم
تطعيمهم ،
شكرًا لك وابقى آمنًا  الدكتور فوشي
حسنًا ، لذا فإن كلا اللقاحين الذي
نتحدث عنه هو لقاح موديرنا
ولقاح fisa
هو ما يسمى دفعة أولية
واحدة حقنة واحدة تليها حقنة أخرى في
غضون أربعة أسابيع
28 يومًا ، لذا فإن
ما لديك هو أنك تحصل على درجة ليست
مثالية
ولكن بدرجة ما مناعة من المناعة بعد
أسبوعين
من الجرعة الأولى وهذا ليس كذلك  الأمثل
بعد الجرعة الثانية تحصل على مناعة مثالية في
أي مكان
من سبعة إلى عشرة أيام بعد الجرعة الثانية
عندما تنظر إلى التجربة
السريرية كانت البيانات والفعالية عالية جدًا من
94 إلى 95
حيث كان هناك عدد قليل جدًا من الأشخاص الذين
تم تطعيمهم والذين  في الواقع
أصيبوا بالعدوى
وحصلوا على الأعراض ، من الواضح أن الأشخاص
الذين لم يحصلوا على اللقاح ستظهر عليهم
الأعراض بعد
خمسة ستة أيام من
إصابتهم بالعدوى ،
ولكن إذا فشل الفرد في اللقاح ،
فمن المتوقع أن تظهر عليهم الأعراض
في نفس
الإطار الزمني كما لو  لم يتم تطعيمهم
ربما
بعد يومين تأخروا بسبب
استجابة مناعية جزئية ، كل هذه البيانات
متاحة وهذه الأنواع من الأشياء معروفة
ل  الأفراد
عند إعدادهم
للقاح وعندما يأخذون موافقة مستنيرة
في التجربة بمجرد الموافقة على اللقاح ،
توجد قائمة بجميع
الآثار الجانبية المحتملة للقاح نفسه
ولكن ليس المعلومات التي
ذكرها الشخص للتو في
حالة حدوثها  للإصابة بالعدوى
عندما تبدأ في الحصول على أعراض
معروفة جيدًا ، فإن
فترة الحضانة هي من 2 إلى 14
يومًا بمتوسط خمسة أيام تقريبًا تع
م أنه يمكنك الحصول على مناعة أثناء ال
ديث عن dr fauci عن طريق ال
صابة بالعدوى أو
لحصول على  اللقاح هو
توقع أن
الأشخاص الذين يتلقون اللقاح سيكون لديهم
مناعة أطول أو أقوى مقابل الأشخاص الذين
حصلوا على هذه المناعة عن طريق عدوى
سانجاي ، هذا سؤال رائع
حقًا لأن هذا ما
استخدمناه كمعامل لمدى قوة الاستجابة
المناعية
إذا ألقيت نظرة على اللقاح ،
فإن مستوى ونوعية
الأجسام المضادة المعادلة
كانت قابلة للمقارنة بل وحتى أفضل
مما تراه في بلازما
النقاهة.  بالنسبة للأشخاص الذين أصيبوا بالفعل
وطوروا استجابة مناعية ، فإنهم على
الأقل جيد
مثل الاستجابة المرتبطة بالعدوى الطبيعية ،
لذا أخبر الطبيب مصدرين من كبار المسؤولين في الإدارة
CNN أن مركز السيطرة على الأمراض
سيقلل قريبًا عدد
أيام الحجر الصحي من 14 إلى
ربما 10 أو ربما حتى  7 أيام مع
الاختبار السلبي ،
هل تعتقد أن المزيد من الأشخاص سيتبعون
القواعد إذا اضطروا إلى الحجر الصحي لفترة
زمنية أقصر ، وأعتقد أنهم
سيتبعون قواعد الحجر الصحي ، وتذكر
عندما
تم إعداد الحجر الصحي لمدة 14 يومًا ، كان ذلك
مبكرًا جدًا في  الوباء
عندما تكون لدينا معلومات أقل مما لدينا
اليوم ، وإذا نظرت بالفعل إلى
الدراسات
التي تتناول متى يصبح شخص ما
معديًا بالفعل ولديه علامات وأعراض سريرية
بعد التعرض ،
فإننا نرى أن معظم ذلك يحدث
خلال تلك الأيام السبعة الأولى ،
لذلك  أه إذا كان أحدهم يتابع شخصًا ما لمدة
سبعة أيام مقابل 14
ثم بشكل خاص إذا كان لديك
اختبار سلبي فمن
المحتمل بالفعل  لديك تأثير إيجابي أكثر
بكثير من الأشخاص الذين يقولون جيدًا أنني لا أستطيع أن
أفعل 14 يومًا ،
لذا فهم لا يفعلون أي شيء على الإطلاق ،
لذا أعتقد أن هذه خطوة ذكية وستساعدنا في
أن
يكون اللقاح آمنًا لجميع الأعمار  وجميع
الأعراق بالطريقة التي تعمل بها هذه التجارب هي
أن عشرات الآلاف من الأشخاص
يتلقون اللقاح كجزء من
التجارب ، ولكن في النهاية
سيتلقون المليارات من الأشخاص
في عموم السكان ،
لذلك نحتاج إلى جمع المزيد والمزيد من البيانات
و  سيحدث هذا على مدار
السنوات القادمة ،
ما يمكننا قوله على وجه اليقين في هذه
المرحلة هو أنه إذا تم تعليق البيانات ،
فإنها تبدو فعالة
للغاية وآمنة خلال فترة الشهرين الأولين ،
ما هي الآثار الجانبية المحتملة إذا
أخذت هذا
هذا مهم فقط لأن
اللقاح آمن
لا يعني أنه لن تكون هناك
آثار جانبية محتملة
ويمكن أن تجعلك تشعر
بالبؤس لبضعة أيام
تشعر بألم في الذراع والشعور بالتعب الشديد والجريان
وهذا أمر نظامك المناعي.
في حالة التجهيز ، هل نعرف ما إذا كان اللقاح
سيكون له أي
آثار جانبية طويلة المدى جيدًا ، الإجابة المختصرة هي لا
، والطريقة الوحيدة التي يمكنك من خلالها معرفة
ذلك حقًا هي بمرور الوقت ،
ما نعرفه هو أن هذه الشركات
تقدم شهرين  من بيانات السلامة
على لقاحاتهم لمدة شهرين
لأنه عندما تحدث معظم الآثار الضارة
إذا كانت ستحدث على الإطلاق ،
هل يحقنونني ببعض من الفيروس
في اللقاح مثل هذا
السؤال المهم ومن المهم إدراك
كيفية عمل هذا اللقاح المحدد  أنت
لا تصاب بفيروس أو حتى
فيروس مميت أو تضعف الفيروس في الواقع ،
ما تحصل عليه هو
رمز جيني لجزء من الفيروس ، لذلك لا توجد
طريقة يمكن أن تصاب بها بالفعل
من اللقاح نفسه ، أنا قلق من
أن اللقاح  يتم تسريعها ،
هل جعلوها سريعة جدًا بشكل جيد ، ما
يستغرق عادةً
سنوات لتطوير اللقاح يستغرق شهورًا فقط
هذه المرة ،
لكنه لا يزال يخضع للفحوصات والتوازنات ،
حيث خضع للتجارب
السريرية  تتم مراجعتها الآن من قبل علماء إدارة الأغذية والعقاقير
عندما نستعيد تلك البيانات ، سيكون لدينا
فكرة جيدة حقًا ،
هل هذا فعال وهل هو آمن على
الأقل على المدى القصير ،
هل يمكنني العودة إلى طبيعتي بعد
تلقي اللقاح
جيدًا هذا الجزء يعتمد على كيفية  أنت تحدد
الوضع الطبيعي ،
أعتقد لفترة من الوقت في هذا
البلد أننا ما زلنا نرتدي
الأقنعة لأنه لن يتم
تطعيم الجميع في نفس الوقت
الذي تحتاج فيه إلى الوقت لبناء
مناعة القطيع هذه وتجعل من الصعب
على الفيروس  ما زلنا نعيش وننتشر
داخل مجتمع
لا نعرف أيضًا ما إذا كان اللقاح
سيمنع بالفعل العدوى
وانتقالها أو إذا كان
سيمنع الأشخاص ببساطة من الإصابة بالمرض ،
فهذه أسئلة لا تزال مفتوحة
ونأمل أن تتم الإجابة عليها في الأسابيع
والأشهر القادمة